Hmm.
Anyways,
Jacobs smart enough to get out there and which is also not really a testament to
his integrity.
Right?
I mean he's done these terrible things at the behest of his mother because he
wants power and he wants to get it without deserving it.
And then he finally goes too far and he hightails it out of there to his,
to another family member,
to his mother's brother.
And so
it's not exactly the world's most heroic story,
that's for sure.
And so now there's an interlude here,
and this is a really interesting interlude.
It's,
it's the story of Jacob's ladder.
So he's off to visit La band or lab and who's,
uh,
his,
his mother's brother and on the way he,
he,
he has a sleep and he lighted upon a certain place and tarried there all night
because the sun was sad and he took of the stones of that place and put them for
his pillows,
which seems to indicate very bad planning on,
on his part and,
and lay down in that place to sleep.
And he dreamed and behold a ladder set up on the earth.
And the top of it reached to heaven and beheld the angels of God ascending and
descending on it.
And behold the lord stood above it and said,
I am the Lord God of Abraham,
thy father and the god of Isaac,
the land we're on Belle liased to the I will give it and to thy seed.
And so this story of Jacob's ladder has really possessed the imagination of the
West.
And there's a reason for that.
It's because it's an archetypal story because the idea of a ladder that reaches
to heaven is one of the oldest ideas of mankind.
So you'll find it widely distributed among the shamanic cultures,
for example.
And it's a hallmark of psychedelic experience.
That's another way of thinking about it,
which is a very peculiar thing.
So there's one representation of,
of the ladder you see got up at the top there.
I'm peeking out from the clouds.
Now you know that sort of where we get the idea that God is in heaven and the
heavens up in the sky.
And,
and that's an easy story to make fun of because you know,
we've gotten up to the moon and there is no god there and,
and,
but,
but this,
this is not a reasonable way of conceptualizing what these experiences are
about,
these experiences,
what this is the opening up there that's more like an opening into an alternate
dimension.
That's a better way of thinking about it.
It's beyond like from,
from the Judeo Christian perspective,
one of the things you have to understand is that God is beyond space and time.
He's not in the universe,
he's outside the universe in some manner.
And so the idea that that you have an experience of God and it's op isn't the
APP is the best that the human imagination can do with what's essentially a form
of extra dimensional experience or that's the best way to conceptualize it.
And these experiences aren't rare.
You know,
they,
they make the,
they make up the core of,
of the shamanic tradition.
And so there's an intrusion of the ancient shamanic tradition,
which is tens of thousands of years old into the biblical stories at this point.
Now why Jacob had a essentially shamonic experience is very difficult to tell
because we don't know what these old people we're up to.
Right,
and we don't know how much of the Archaic Tradition,
archaic,
religious tradition was still extent at that at that point in time,
but we certainly do know that our ancient forebears were using psychedelic
substances constantly like am Anita Mascara,
mushrooms,
for example,
which were widely used in India before they became extinct.
That's the theory.
Anyways,
that seemed to be the basis of the Chemical Soma,
which a much has been written about,
and so we hear this as a dream or has a vision and perhaps that's what it was,
but perhaps that wasn't what it was either and perhaps it was an experience that
was induced by I by the same processes that shamonic people have always induced
these experiences and so we're going to go through this a little bit.
So anyways,
there's A.
There's a connection between heaven and earth that opens up.
That's,
that's,
that's the,
that's the vision and there's messenger is moving up and down.
Now,
one way you can conceptualize that is psychologically,
as we already discussed,
that you know,
there,
there are forces within you that are active and alive and you can think of them
in some sense as messengers of the higher self and so you could think about this
as an image of a psychological reality,
but and so we can stick with that,
but,
but
here's some of the representations that have been made.
I really liked the one on the right.
That's William Blake.
I liked the a helix idea and I don't think that that's a fluke.
There are helixes and double helix is in all sorts of images,
imagery,
very ancient and very modern that are associated with both healing and with this
kind of vision.
So,
and you see it in the blake representation.
God is associated with,
well really with the sun and with light,
and you see that on the left as well,
that wherever God is is where light is.
And so that's a very interesting idea as far as I'm concerned as well.